matt how are you
i'm great how are you doing today better
than i deserve what's up
yeah i just got a real
quick question for you i'm trying to
figure out whether or not i should spend
a little extra money to get a trust
um
i got i've got my will in place i went
and met with a a lawyer the other day
and uh he tried to convince me that i
needed one
and i wasn't sure that i do
a trust or a will
uh the trust what was he why did he say
you need her to trust
well i'm i
i've got kind of a unique situation i'm
divorced i've got three minor
kids uh my my net worth is is
approaching about half a million um i
he just said it would be it would
protect the kids a lot better and and
all that stuff and
i
i don't know
he was warning me a lot about the
arizona probate courts and all that so i
was just i was trying to
separate out the sales pitch from what i
actually need so
yeah it sounds like you need a new
lawyer if you can't separate that out
because the law you're supposed to be
there to teach you not sell you
and some of them some of them in the
estate planning world are good teachers
and some of them aren't um do you know
what the probate tax is in arizona
i don't i don't know i don't either off
the top of my head some states have a
very low probate tax like a two or three
percent which would be you know 10 20
000 bucks in this case and it's not
worth screwing with to do a trust just
for that
i don't know why you couldn't draft a
will in arizona that would leave
everything to your children in a trust
upon your death i don't know why it has
to be moved to a trust prior to your
death i
in tennessee i haven't had to do that
the will was strong enough to do that
but if he's saying the probate courts
reverse a will in arizona i would
be questioning whether the wheel was
drafted properly
you see what i'm doing yeah i mean
there's two different issues okay
there's an issue the probate tax if the
tax is really high you can avoid the
probate tax with a trust on some of your
assets
and that might be worth it
maybe
our tax our probate tax in tennessee is
not very high so i haven't had to do
that okay
but in some states it's ultra high
meaning it might be as much as 10 or
something like that and so um
all that to say i want to learn a little
bit more and the fact that you're having
to worry about his advice versus a sales
pitch versus his advice bothers me
enough to maybe you need to get a second
opinion about your estate planning
um because ken we always teach in every
area to get someone with the heart of a
teacher
and it's because what you just said we
don't want you to be sold something
especially in something emotional like
this and most money issues are emotional
you start talking about this kind of
stuff and somebody sells you pretty
quickly on something that and maybe in
their mind maybe it's not even uh
sinister but uh it's it's not sound
there's a difference between the two and
the heart of the teacher as you've
always said when you're sitting down
with a financial advisor anybody you
need to understand what the product is
you need to understand how i need it
yeah yeah
this and this that's right and you go
okay that sounds good let's do it or i
think i'll take that risk that's right
that's right i'll measure that out and
being informed by the way allows for
greater questions i just did a quick
search i'm not saying this is correct
but
just checking into this you're looking
at anywhere from two to five thousand
dollars uh the average cost of probate
errors and so just being informed enough
to go i'm gonna dig into this myself and
become a novice on some information and
make somebody who's who's really in
authority or has the knowledge
make them answer your
somewhat informed questions will help
you don't just rely on them for
everything exactly i mean uh again i
and
i don't practice law and you shouldn't
practice law on google no yeah that's
why you need to you do need to gather
this up and but it's good to start
asking questions the thing i'm looking
for here is the vibe yes that um i'm
being taught and um
you know i'm not being scared or slimed
into something and that that bothered me
more than anything else in that
particular question amy's in dallas
texas hi amy how are you
i'm great mr ramsay are you guys doing
better than we deserve what's up
hi all right so maybe i'm a baby step
fraud but i am in baby step seven but i
never had to be in baby step two
well that's not a fraud you got there
you just you just got to skip some steps
that's kind of nice
but i have um i have six uh seven seven
brothers and sisters and i finally got
one converted over to
to doing your method
and uh another one is very very
interested so where do i start them
total money makeover ramsey plus i'm
willing to pay for anything they need
because if they could still promise me
they'll do it like you you know i don't
mind paying for it
if they fully embrace it ramsey plus
puts more tools and things in their path
because it includes financial peace
university it includes every dollar
premium
and it's gonna you know we're gonna be
all up in your
face for months on end if you get a book
you can leave it as a as a coaster on
your coffee table and sometimes that
happens with total money makeover total
money makeovers got all the information
but the activity and the pro activity of
being in financial peace university is
by far the best thing we do for money in
this building
and so
uh if you can get if you get a
commitment out of now that's a hundred
dollars versus twenty dollars okay
so but if you get a solid commitment out
of them
that's the route i would go matter of
fact i'll just give you ramsey plus
under the condition that you get a firm
commitment to them to fully embrace
financial peace university go through
every lesson and do the every dollar
budget if they're not going to give you
that then don't take the gift okay
yes sir
because i'll i'll just stir up trouble
in their house that's all i'll do with
that otherwise so you hang on and kelly
will i'll sign you guys up for sign your
help you get your siblings signed up
once we get this figured out one thing i
would add for this amy is make sure that
they're ready for it and what i mean by
that is i don't mean you know nobody's
ever ready to do anything at some point
you have to step into it but what i mean
by that is they need to acknowledge
that they really have a problem because
even the most well-meaning friend family
member teacher uh until this are they
just nodding to get you off their back
yeah that's what we're looking for
because you know here's the deal you
will invest a lot of energy and
enthusiasm in this and i'm not saying
they're not ready but i'm saying as as a
family member here
um they need to know that they've got a
problem and that they're ready for a
solution as opposed to you going i think
you have a problem here's a great
solution you give them too much and they
don't see their need
um it's not going to be as effective so
if to the extent that they haven't
identified this you're not trying to
help them see it so kelly what we can do
is we can give her a total money
makeover book
and tell her to come back if she gets
firm commitment and you also give her
yeah ramsay plus let's do that that way
we don't uh turn on a fire hose when the
poor guy goes up to the water fountain
to get a drink because that's what i
mean if you're going to go all in ramsey
plus i mean natural beach university
we'll take you there baby yes we'll take
you there but uh it's not for the faint
of heart because we're gonna bring it
you're gonna change man you're gonna get
her done
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
thank you for joining us america ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today he's host of the ken coleman show
where we talk about your career we talk
about your job
we talk about all the things going on
out there right now the great
resignation is real it really is dave
we're uh hurtling towards 20 plus
million people have changed jobs since
august of 2021
and uh the trends look like it's going
to continue to happen to the point now
where you've got a lot of people just
moving from one bus to the next bus
chasing you know uh more money hopefully
a better culture they're looking for
meaning in their work they're looking
for a leader who cares about them that's
what they should be doing that's that's
well in some cases they're just jumping
sometimes they're just going just for
the paycheck which you and i know wears
off um it has profound negative effects
on your health your life and so many
ways when you just start doing something
that you find meaning for so one of the
guys i've read a lot lately and i've
enjoyed um and just because i like how
he stirs things up yes uh he's an edgy
thinker and a brilliant mind is jordan
peterson he's got a lot of things going
on out there and uh there's a thing
going viral on tick tock of him talking
about uh working the miserable
job i want to play that clip and um
and then ken have you guys have you
comment on it
say i have a job i hate it's like well
yeah but i'm not dying from it's like
not as bad as it can be so you think
well i can't jump out of this job
because what about all the risk it's
like yeah no kidding you got to get your
resume in order you got to send it out
then you have to go get interviewed and
maybe you're not any good at that you
have to come up with a story while
you're a good employee what about all
these risks if i go look for a new job
what about the risks for you to stay
with this job you absolutely hate well
let's think that through okay so i have
this dead end job i hate it i'm getting
better where am i going to be in five
years you're gonna be just like you are
now except a lot more of what's good
about you is going to be gone and a lot
more of what's terrible is going to be
amplified because it kills your spirits
yeah so it's like you think oh my god
there's a terrible risk in pursuing this
new job it's like yeah there is a
terrible risk there's a terrible risk
and you stand with your job right now
one of the things that's real really
freeing to understand is that you're
screwed no matter what you do
[Laughter]
is positive yeah i i have while he's a
brilliant mind i take issue with two
things he said there
uh first of all that's just not true
you're not screwed to whatever you do i
mean we've got a thousand people here
that would testify that that not being
true no i mean he's screwed he's saying
you're screwed if you look if you're in
a miserable job and you look for it
you've got the risk of looking uh and
nobody's saying the risk of staying and
both those are either one of those two
options are screwed if yes yeah if you
look at it that way but i don't think
you have to i don't think you have to
look at it that way i don't that's my
point i i i don't think that you have to
look at changing jobs as soon as i argue
i'd like to get him on here to argue i'd
love to argue with him as you know i
enjoy a good argument as well uh but
here's my point
it doesn't have to be so risky
risk is basically a acknowledgement of
i'm afraid that something bad is going
to happen or there is a high probability
that's my point number one if you move
to something that a you actually are
qualified for and you have a high
probability of doing a good job and you
have good character guess what and the
people you're working for are good and
they're not jerks and so the work
they're doing is good that's right and
honorable so now the probability of it
working out is skyrocketed and that's
the reality that's hired for that job
before you quit your other one that's
the other thing i don't know how where
the risk is that's my whole point what's
the risk your life's going to get better
low temperatures are screwed either way
let me that's right let me tell you what
the risk is in not pursuing work that
you actually are good at
talent that you actually love which is
passion and that actually you connect to
the results of the work that's mission
here's the risk dave that you get to the
end of your life
and you are full of regret because you
never pursued that contribution that
somewhere in your heart somewhere along
the way you knew you desire to make in
fact now delineating people can now
delineate for me the difference between
i hate my job and it's sucking the
marrow out of my bones
and
i just discovered this is like work and
it's not always perfect yeah a big
difference because i i also run into
people on the other in the spectrum who
uh quit at the drop of a hat right the
first time they encounter any kind
of obstacle like someone for the first
time telling them they're not beautiful
pretty and smart and oh my god their
little feelings and they're gone well
you just identified what's really going
on but i just know well i'll tell you
you've identified what's going on is
that they've been psychologically shaken
and here's where it comes from
well by a phrase that we've adopted as
truth and we've all heard this uttered
before i don't even know who came up
with it
but it's if you love what you do you'll
never work a day in your life that's a
bunch of hogwash i've said it well
that's
it's garbage let me tell you why you and
i work our butts off we do love what we
do we have hard long days here sometimes
really hard days and some days suck some
days do suck this idea some seasons and
some seasons in a calling yes sir will
suck yeah that's what and don't confuse
that with you know because if you have
the expectation snowflake that every day
is going to be easy and you get a trophy
at the end of every day and you ate
gummy bears with john de loni at the end
of every session right you know if you
get this if you if this is your view on
life you're about to get disappointed
puppy you will spend your entire life
wandering yeah like a tumbleweed through
the old western movies that's different
than stay in the job no matter what for
22 years and you hate it every moment
that's unnecessary suffering that that's
those are two different things yeah you
are settling in that case you are
settling for
uh mediocre or you are settling for
below average or you are settling for
suck so let me tell you uh jim collins
talks about this he and i were having a
discussion about it in person not long
ago
the and he talks about in the last book
uh uh great by choice
he said people are not
afraid
of
something
that uh uh
is a stated
that they're not afraid of real problems
most of the time
but ambivalence yes not knowing it
scares people to death yeah and so
sitting in your job not knowing what
peterson was talking about yeah that
those two kinds of things not knowing
causes you to not move that scares
people to death yes so the way you get
past the not knowing is you go through
your seven steps it's the seven stages
in the book from paycheck to purpose get
clear at stage one why is clarity so
important you just addressed it what
collins is saying is ambivalence will
kill you when we d it's it's like
driving into deep fog uh or a heavy rain
to where you can't see past the hood of
your car that is terrifying we
immediately pump the brakes we pull over
the side of the road it's the same
psychological feeling when someone goes
i don't know what my future is i don't
know how i get there i mean that's a
real problem and so it is a paralyzing
uh factor when we go i don't know so why
is get clear so important when i'm clear
on all the different things i can do
even if one of the options is painful as
long as i'm clear that's better than not
knowing well if you show somebody
watching well let's look at let's look
at the context of the ramsey show for
decades we've celebrated people and we
will celebrate today people that have
gotten debt free when you showed them a
clear path via the baby steps they knew
how stinking hard it was going to be
they went to the first couple classes of
financial peace university they were
like are you kidding me this dude that's
yelling me yelling at me on the screen i
gotta do that they know it's gonna be
hard but they still do it why because
they see on the other side of it they
see freedom from debt
seems pleasant at the time but it yields
a harvest of righteousness when we see
we can do it when we see a desired
future we will endure pain so i and so
completely agree with uh that was a
50-second clip i completely agree with
47 seconds of petersburg yeah absolutely
but you're screwed either way i don't
agree with that i don't agree with that
either it's classical it's a great line
classic peterson but you're not you are
screwed either way if you freeze
yeah and if you accept the fact except
the fact that risk is the only way to
get out that's right you can you can
limit the risk by following a very clear
path and a clear process for landing the
other position that is better pay but
more importantly a better environment
with a better upside that's right better
people and a better product than you're
doing now and you can leave the dumpy
job
with class with class and never you've
given it a fair shot yes and know that
when you went into it here it is the
seven stages are get clear i know what i
want to do why i want to do it then i
got to get qualified that's the ticket
to the dance i got to get connected dave
because that's where opportunities come
to me i'm not beating doors down then
i'm going to get the opportunity to get
started now i'm focused on getting
promoted climbing up i'm going to
eventually get that dream job and then
i'm working like no one else to give
myself away i've made gobs of money
experienced tremendous meaning now it's
about leaving a legacy those are the
seven stages in the book from paycheck
to purpose and they work by the way
nothing risky about this
paycheck to purpose at
ramseysolutions.com
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage diane is with us hi
diane how are you i'm great i'm excited
well we're so honored to have you where
do you live i live in charleston west
virginia oh very nice town very cool
well welcome to nashville and all the
way here to do a debt-free scream yes
sir how much have you paid off i've paid
off 31
718 dollars and 31 cents i love it how
long did that take you 36 months good
for you and your range of income during
that time i'm on social security and a
small pension i've uh
was between 19 and 20 000
per year per year and you paid off 32
036 months how did you eat
god god provided i'm telling you manna
oh my goodness so what kind of debt was
the 32 000 well it was a personal loan
it was
some
medical uh credit cards
and um
oh
what else did that that's good enough
good job well that's a good thing my
mortgage oh your mortgage
oh yeah there's that
looking at a weird lady i love it no
house mortgage
way to go very cool all right so you are
100
debt free i'm debt-free how long has it
been since you were 100 debt-free i've
never been that free i was never a
natural saver i
raised my two daughters
alone
and
[Music]
i spent you know what i needed to spend
i didn't yeah i just wasn't saying so
you're a retired single mom right and
how old are your daughters
well my my oldest daughter has passed
and my
youngest daughter is here with me today
she's going to be 50 next month awesome
very cool what'd you do what was your
career
i worked
as a an accountant
or accounting
clerk yeah bookkeeper and so forth yeah
i worked for blue cross and blue shield
for years okay good and that gave you
the money to raise those kids and right
and here you are retired and only 32
thousand dollars and you knock it out
knocked it out so what happened 36
months ago because this is a big change
for you
well 36 months ago um
wasn't the beginning of my story was was
in 2016.
i got a call from my granddaughter that
lives in wisconsin
my daughter's daughter
and
she
told me
that her mom was in the hospital
and i had no i had no savings or
anything i couldn't get to her
my oldest daughter was
a kidney failure in the hospital in
charleston at the same time
and i had no way to get to wisconsin
and
i called my church and some friends from
my church and
asked them to pray to
for some kind of solution for i didn't
know what to do
so they uh
they rallied around and come to my house
and gave me money to
get to wisconsin to see my daughter
because
i didn't think she was going to make it
she was in a coma and i did they didn't
think she was going to make it
if i wanted to see her i
had to find a way so
my church reality around me and
you know
gave me the money and then my grandson
was there and he he drove me we didn't
have time for a plane so he drove me the
way all the way wow
so wow
so then that was that's a that's a
poignant wake-up call yes it is so
you're saying i got to do something i'm
not going to be in this position again
right never again so then
my oldest daughter passed in 2017
and so i was i was just an emotional
wreck
so i had to i had to do something to to
go through the grieving process and you
know get over her situation
too and
uh
it just uh
i didn't know what to do so
i've
i started with uh
essential oils and
you know just to
help me emotionally and it and it really
did i felt like it really did but
i went gung-ho with it and overboard and
put it on a credit card and just run
myself you know into debt and then how
did you get connected to us well
a friend from church had
uh and i think in 2015 they put
a financial peace class at the church
but at the time i
i didn't feel like i needed it or
they asked for a hundred dollars and i
didn't have a hundred dollars at the
time to pay for it so i didn't
i didn't join it that time but i
i knew
after
all this happened i knew who i could
contact so i contacted them and asked
to borrow their book you know that maybe
i didn't know if you all had a book you
know
to teach you how to do it or what you
know
so i asked for the book and
so i read it wasn't the total money
makeover it was the like a money book
i'm not sure complete guide to money
money yeah
so i read that and then
in
july
of 2018
i i was
i i normally we had would have a cookout
with my
oldest daughter but she had passed and
so i was alone at you know that fourth
of july so i i just got on youtube once
once i've read that book i got on
youtube and started asking
about dave ramsey and all that
all that all that
how can i how can i get out of debt yeah
but i did pray i asked the lord you know
lord i need to get out of debt
and so um
i started binge watching
youtube
and your shows you are not the normal
demographic that binge watches youtube i
was telling you
that'll be your granddaughter i was
desperate to get out of debt and so i
i
i did uh ben's watch and went back and
just
i don't know i heard you tell about the
the first debt free scream and i thought
and then when i saw the debt freezing
scream i thought
this is the plan that i need i'm gonna
do
this so good you are
all right i'm gonna do something that
would cause my mama to whip me
but i'm gonna do it anyway because i
think you're precious oh boy are you
gonna do it damn yeah i'm gonna do it
okay i gotta know how old you are
i'm 74. 74. i was 70 when i started this
and
in july of 2018. and the reason i wanted
to be inappropriate for those of you
that are listening we have the benefit
of looking at this beautiful lady but
those of you that are listening i want
this to get your highlighter out and say
anybody can do this and it's never too
late that's right because you're a
walking you're a walking billboard
you're incredible thank you you are
amazing thank you on 20 years inspiring
you did this on no money yeah 19 20 000
bucks and you pay off 32 000 in credit
card debt from the essential oil thing
went bad and get the mortgage paid off
and everything else wow i'm so impressed
with you the story about behind the
mortgage payoff when i first started i
only owed about six thousand dollars
and so i paid it down to like twenty
five hundred dollars and i was just you
know
i'm a facebook junkie so i put it on
facebook that i'm a high tech lady here
yeah yeah absolutely i put it on
facebook that woohoo i'm down to 2500 on
my mortgage and so my brother-in-law
that i hadn't seen for 30 years hadn't
talked to him because my husband and i
were divorced and so
you know we wasn't close or anything
but his wife had a facebook page
he wasn't
you know on facebook but he stalked her
so
he saw that and he said usually at
christmas time he would find a family in
the church or something that he would
give to
so he
i was in wisconsin that christmas
with my daughter and i got a phone call
that his wife had said my husband
saw your
facebook page he wanted to pay it off
i don't want to run out of time you're
amazing thank you so much for being here
that's an amazing story you're an
impressive impressive lady thank you
all right it is diane in charleston west
virginia 32 000 paid off in 36 months
house and everything
retired on social security making 19 to
20 she did this this is an amazing lady
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three
two
one
ah dead friend
[Music]
wow
that came from the soul there
first time in 74 years
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so here's the deal if 74 year old diane
can pay off everything in three years on
social security
i think all your excuses were just
completely ripped out of your hands and
you get to go
that's pretty much a mic drop in your
face
some of you've been whining and sitting
around talking about how the economy's
bad and biden's in the white house and
you've got all these dead gum excuses
while
diane just goes and does it
yeah boom it's amazing
hey when the team gets together at
ramsey solutions we talk a lot about our
mission to change
america's toxic culture it makes us mad
to see people trapped in debt or to
watch kids sign away their future for a
student loan and for the folks that work
here this is not a j.o.b it is a mission
if that sounds like a passion that you
share
you've got to check out all the exciting
roles ramsey solutions is looking to
fill
asap there's never been a better time to
find a job doing work you love we've got
need for developers ux designers writers
to help us build digital products that
actually do something they change
people's lives
to see what it's like to do work that
matters with us before you apply you can
follow us on instagram and facebook by
searching ramsay careers apply your
dream job apply for your dream job at
ramseysolutions.comcareers
and
you could actually go from paycheck to
purpose the way ken
talks about that's exactly right
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five cole is with us
in chicago hey cole what's up
hi dave uh not too much i don't want to
take too much of your time so i'll give
you a little snapshot of what's going on
with me so
i am 157 000 in student loan debt i have
a hundred and twenty one thousand
dollars on a mortgage
i make sixty five thousand dollars base
with a commission
that brings me to around a hundred
thousand dollars at the end of the year
i'm going through a divorce and once
it's finalized i'll have
somewhere around fifty thousand dollars
in cash to my name at that point and
i just need to point the right direction
on what i should do to be a good steward
of my money
how long you been
married
uh just two years but we were together
for seven okay
wow i'm sorry
um what's your career field
i'm a lawyer
okay all right
and uh how long have you been practicing
law
this will be going on four years this
may
prior i'm in private practice now and
prior to that i was a
deputy prosecuting attorney for the
state okay
all right so now you're making a little
money for the first time that's good
okay because you were starving before um
compared to your 150 000 of student loan
debt for to get the law degree anyway
um yeah that doesn't exactly set you up
for uh junior prosecutor money when you
got 150k in debt you need more money and
so it's a good thing you're making some
so what we teach coal is to work your
way through all of your debt except your
home first it sounds like you don't have
any debt except the student loan in the
home is that right
that's correct okay
and um so
i'm going to take the 50 000 and i'm
going to throw it at your student loan
debt i'm going to leave one thousand
dollars in a baby starter emergency fund
we call that baby step one two is get
out of debt everything but your house
and i'm gonna roll up your sleeves
because you don't have anybody to hold
accountable except the person in your
mirror you don't have to talk anybody
into anything except the person in your
mirror now your life is very clean and
very simple sadly and i'm sure your
heart's broken i'm sure it's not been a
good process but but you're there and
and the bad news is you're there the
good news is you get to make a choice
now and you can get after and knock this
debt out in no time i mean how fast you
pay off a hundred thousand making a
hundred thousand i'll help you with this
two years or less
you live on beans and rice and you knock
this stinking student loan debt out
otherwise you're gonna be like your
brother broke law your friends walking
around with debt around your neck 15
years from now because you haven't dealt
with it
right
get after it dude that's what i would do
if i woke up in your shoes i would use
this opportunity
and and and you know you know while
you're healing from the broken heart and
the grieving the the messed up situation
you've gone through and there has to be
some of that even if it's a fairly uh
lightweight situation it still breaks
your heart still leaves scars and
scratches on your face metaphorically
hopefully only and so uh you know you've
got to go from there and but the good
news is it's a clean blank slate and i
just roll up my sleeves and get with it
i would too to that end i would be
asking how can i increase that
commission so i think he was on about a
65 000 base or somewhere in that range
and he's getting up to a hundred you
know at this point he needs to heal
anyway he didn't need any relationships
i'd be thinking about how i could use
that law degree uh you're in private
practice how can i increase that
commission because i
increase that commission that's it as i
increase the commission i increase my
speed of which i pay off that student
loan yeah and so i'd lean in and throw
the 50 grand at it get on a really tight
budget not have much of a life
um and just tear into work and for a
short period of time pay a price so that
you're free for the rest of your whole
life
too many people look at medical degrees
and law degree student loan debt is
something you're going to have around
for 20 years when you have the income to
knock it out in
two or three
and you know in your case it's two
because you got this 50k to throw at it
that's what i would do if i woke up in
your shoes
hang on i'm gonna send you a copy of the
book the total money makeover that'll
give you the exact steps on how to do
that amy's in wisconsin hi amy welcome
to the ramsay show
hi nice to meet you guys and be on um
the show
sure what's up
um so this question is more so for ken
because it's regarding my career
um so just a little bit of background
i i'm 22 years old i've been a nurse now
for
almost three years
and um
i guess it's not exactly
what i'm passionate about you completed
nursing school and passed your bars at
19
he has um i i was
i just turned 20 when i
like an overachiever you got with it
yeah
um but um my senior year of high school
i was between like dental hygiene
um and even wanting to be like a dentist
in nursing
but my i feel like my parents more so
push me the nursing route and now i just
i don't know if i'm totally
satisfied and happy in my career why
give me a short amount of time what's
the number one cause of uncertainty
about nursing what is it
um i just feel like it's caused me a lot
of
like issues with anxiety and even you
know some depression
um i was working a lot of nights
in a hospital and now i i've
transitioned to a clinic setting
and i feel like right now my anxiety and
it's it's a lot better now that i'm
working normal hours and it's less well
you kind of came through a a a pandemic
that's a once in a hundred year event
yeah
here's what i want you to do i i i want
you i'm going to give you a homework
assignment okay i don't want you to make
any decisions based on what you've
experienced in the past we're going to
start fresh today and we're going to get
clear i want you to clarify and verify
so number one i want you to walk through
what is better about the clinic side of
things and the hospital and the hours if
your hours were better and i want you to
talk to nurses who have better hours and
maybe work in not just a clinic
environment but other nursing
environments once you do a full-scale
kind of research project into the areas
of nursing that you don't know a lot
about and look at the hours ago what was
driving the anxiety okay and maybe even
see a counselor not a bad idea okay now
before you make a decision about dental
hygiene or being a dentist same thing i
want you to hang out with some dental
hygienist coffee lunch
and get the ends and the outs the ups
the downs of that type of work before we
make any kind of decision we can't let
emotions
make us move from something we have to
allow our brain and our heart to
actually get on the same page when we're
hurting we're not very clear so a we
want to get healthy if we need to get
healthy emotionally that'll give us
greater perspective b i want you to do
some actual research on other types of
nursing and the dental hygiene and in
doing all that here's what i know that
is a process called clarify and verify
and when you clarify
the ends the outs the ups the downs of
nursing and dental hygienic work or or
being a dentist here's what's going to
happen your heart will verify which
direction you need to go don't make any
decisions until you do that and the last
two years
are not a good that's performed to make
a decision about your career from
i would have quit doing this if the last
two years were the reason i do it
so
it's just almost true good god
oh hang on kelly's gonna send you a copy
of paycheck to purpose this is the
ramsey ship
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
paycheck to purpose is my co-host today
he also hosts the ken coleman show where
we talk about careers and work and
loving your job and getting a new job
and all that kind of stuff and of course
we talk about your relationships here
your money here
your marriages here your parenting here
it all shows up here on the ramsay show
ken the other thing we talk about on
this show is the horrible
awful yes greedy
rich people yes i'm so sick of the
greedy rich people that are taking over
the world
and the poor little guy who won't work
and go get him a job and make him some
money he just doesn't have a chance
living in his mother's basement playing
mario kart that's right so we need to
tax those sure that's police plane it's
probably mario yeah they need to give
their fair share over to the the greedy
rich people should wander and stop being
rich they should stop being successful
yes because we all know that everyone
that has money is by definition evil yes
it is the answer of we we know this is
the answer and the if we if we fix this
socialism will do it for us
we need to get some socialism and
everyone should get a trophy that's true
and no snowflakes should melt that's
correct this is true
and so everybody ought to have a chance
it's just off all these gritty rich
people because i know what we try to do
every so often on the show is we try to
feature a greedy rich person and the
horrible things that they are doing
in our culture today today we're going
to pick on the greedy rich person elon
musk
elon musk says spacex starlink
satellites active over ukraine
after a request from embattled countries
leaders he's made his satellite time
available to the ukrainians uh for free
yeah
putin knocked out their internet and so
he got a direct appeal from the
president of ukraine he said sure hold
on one i'll move a satellite over there
something you can't do
unless you're elon yeah i can't move a
satellite over there you can't either
you can't move a satellite over there
but we're not greedy rich people what's
that joystick look like by the way
like somewhere at spacex somebody's got
essentially a joystick or something or
is it all computer keyboard i don't know
these are questions i have yahoo news
reporting valerie putin's unprovoked
invasion has left parts of the country
without internet while spacex has
launched thousands of communication
satellites to bring broadband to hard to
reach areas of the world we should bring
the internet too hard to reach areas of
the world because that's what greedy
rich people do because of course we know
that those hard to reach areas of the
world those people pay a lot
and they're going to make all their
money back
no they don't have any money you doobs
okay so just in case you're wondering
but anyway users on the ground access
the broadband signals beamed back to
earth using a kit sold by spacex
whether you try to cut while you try to
colonize mars russia will try to occupy
the ukraine
while your rockets successfully land
from space russian rockets attack
ukrainian civil people we ask you to
provide ukraine with starlink nations
stations to address sane russians to
stand
um a
an official from ukraine tweeted this at
elon and elon did uh he moved the
satellites into place and are making
them available to the ukrainians for
free and this just happens to be
obviously one of the richest people on
the planet a very well-known brand and
obviously an extraordinary current event
but what i know about a lot of rich
people is
if the general public especially all the
snowflakes who want the rich to pay
their fair share if they had
a scintilla
of of evidence oh look at that
of how look up cintilla that's a small
number it is it's it's a very small
number yeah it's very
very small but if they had any clue
how those rich people give every day to
do extraordinary things for people uh
they they would they would shut their
mouths and sit down they just don't have
any clues you know why because good rich
people bait this with facts oh i know
i'm gonna use facts
actual numbers and research
that would be that's that's not the way
you argue things you're just supposed to
be emotional and go on twitter
isn't it funny the irony is those are
the people if you add up what people in
north america the united states of
america private citizens give to
charitable causes
and people in need every year it dwarfs
the entire economy of most small nations
yeah
but we don't talk about that no because
rich people are evil and they should be
punished and they're not paying their
fair share that's right senator warren
is after elon musk because he didn't pay
the taxes she thought he should pay that
was a mistake because he apparently hits
back a little clap back there and wore
her butt out but um
yum
yeah it's true it's it's
as we say down in tennessee she bit off
more than she could chew there
so um this is a problem but uh yeah just
one more evil person doing horrible
things in the world making uh free
free uh broadband available to the
ukrainians by moving his own personal
satellite over their nation to cause it
i know not something i got up this
morning and thought i could possibly do
yeah he didn't send he didn't say that
this morning i'm gonna move the
satellite right that doesn't come these
are not conversations i'm in no he
didn't ship a bunch of food and clothes
he moved a satellite or two or three
it's extraordinary
giving the country internet apparently
something the united states of america
government couldn't figure out a way to
do it oh of course not yeah that was
that's impossible because i'm sure it
begs the question dave are you going to
go to space
are you am i going to go to school yeah
dude i live in space
lola seriously this guy spacex
this is gonna be he's gonna let me go
well it's not about let you he'll he'll
take your ticket you're gonna be able to
pay for this in three to five years
it'll you know i'm just asking would you
go if it's affordable and you're looking
i'm looking i'm waiting on my credit
card to frequent flyer miles to build up
well then you're not going
that's a good one i like that
that that would be rich dave ramsey
finally gets a credit card so he could
go to
not going to happen
oh i don't know ken
you strike me somebody they would try
that
i just did a i just did my first um
about 18 months ago did my first
parachute i know i had done this first
time i'd done what was that like
skydiving we've actually not talked
about the last it was an absolute
adrenaline what was your fear factor
on a scale of one to ten i thought i was
gonna pee in my pants that's what i
figured i was gonna be that guy that
would be the last one
i thought i was gonna be crying like
whatever right and you know what i just
i i never got nervous they did such a
good job prepping us right and the
company was so professional right uh and
um and they've got these cool things
that they they hook to your parachute
that if the guy you're strapped to dies
and his doesn't come out yeah once you
reach a certain altitude it
automatically deploys your chute all
right so i'm like this is really
completely idiot-proof i mean now were
you like four shoots involved one of
them is gonna go off i think i'm gonna
be okay so you went i probably had more
risk driving over there
you know
jumping out of the airplane so i was not
by the time i got up there i was excited
but i was not now were you did you have
the instructor yeah oh that's the only
way to do it front or behind
with rookies you they have to be in uh
let's see you're in front of them
so you're looking down yeah no
obstructions we're flying you're just
looking at the earth
hurtling at you so fun very impressive
it was a blast i'm going again yeah
adrenaline rush man we got the bottom we
went to eat breakfast my hands were
shaking not because i was tired but the
adrenaline dumped i could only it's
amazing it was so funny
yeah maybe i'll go fly with him i think
he's going to go to school right now i'm
just concerned about elon's generosity i
can't believe he's an evil rich person
of this magnitude you can bless him out
when you're on the shuttle with him
that's it you know you evil rich people
stop your generosity you're giving evil
rich people everywhere a bad name
this is the ramsey chef
[Applause]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
well it's tax season and i don't know
anyone who loves that unless you're an
accountant the truth is most of us dread
filing taxes it makes us mad it's a pain
it's confusing and if filing taxes
wasn't bad enough the software most
people use hits you with extra fees or
worse they try to sell you all kinds of
products especially getting you into
debt
but filing your taxes does not have to
be horrible we created ramsey smart tax
to give you software you can actually
trust
smart tax has steps that are simple and
clear so you know you've done your taxes
right no more headaches no more second
guessing we'll never tack on a surprise
fee or sell you or sell your info to
some scummy company
when you sign up for ramsey plus it's
even easier you actually file your
federal taxes on ramsey smart tax for
free and what that means is you go to
ramsey plus and you need to start a free
trial and get into ram get into
financial peace university and get into
every dollar and part of that package is
when you're in ramsey plus you get to
use ramsey smart tax free so that's how
you ought to do it
go to ramseysolutions.com
ramseyplus and start your free trial
ramseysolutions.com
ramsey plus our question today comes
from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free free samples free shipping and new
promos all the time this is an
incredible american company if you need
window coverings window blinds use the
promo code ramsey
blinds.com today's question comes from
paul in virginia when i went to college
25 years ago for a bs in engineering it
served me well both in knowledge and
getting a well-paying job my wife and i
planned on paying for our 16 year old
son's college education but we assumed
it would end in him achieving a degree
instead he's considering a technical
certification in audio engineering for
live performances the certification is
twelve thousand dollars but we are on
the fence about whether this is a wise
path to pursue unlike in my day good
paying jobs
now don't seem to always require a
traditional four-year degree what are
your thoughts on a technical
certification versus a traditional
college-based degree and would you pay
for your kids technical certification
assuming
it was something widely recognized in
that industry well the first part of the
question to address is
does
the destination scare you
or is it the path to the destination so
what i'm saying here is as parents
i don't know what's really driving you
being concerned about his future if it
is being an audio engineer and being
successful then you can help your son do
the research and you as parents can see
what does a path look like where all the
different ways that audio engineers can
go
then the certification itself it's not
about is it widely recognized
the issue is is it absolutely necessary
to get your son that entry-level
qualification necessary and so if it is
a reputable uh program that gives a
mandatory certification absolutely i'm
fine with that but i think the fear here
is
the destination and you know where do
you want your kid to go uh with a
college education because my twofold
question for parents is this is college
the only way for your kid to get where
they want to go and if it's not the only
way is it the best way if you've got a
no to either one of those two questions
then there is going to be another path
and a certification is the way to do it
or it might be a trade school but ask
those two questions and answer those and
it takes away a lot of the fear of the
unknown so the trades
and technical certifications are worth
more
than a lot of college degrees in terms
of getting
uh getting a career
a diesel mechanic right now is making
100 grand
okay a master's in social work's making
38 grand
okay so let's just talk this through
i mean that that's what you're you know
if you're looking at that um and so but
are all college degrees bad no are all
technical certifications superior no i
mean you could get a technical
certification in making pottery ash
trays
and be broke the rest of your life
okay because there's not a big call for
ash trash today pottery ones for sure
sadly okay just saying yeah unless you
live in sedona right so um but the uh uh
but you know there's there's a thing
here right so but but and so if you go
get sort of microsoft certifications
and you load up on those uh you know in
the technical world or in this uh
particularly in security
and internet security uh you make a
couple hundred grand and never set foot
into college
uh so yeah you can go that route so the
question is is not specific not br if
it's broadly are technical
certifications an okay way to go in
today's world you're dead come right
they actually always have been yes but
no one just admitted it because we were
a bunch of college schnapps right and
and college was the only way in college
was the only way in college the only way
and then college became so stinking
expensive and people got stupid about
the stuff they were studying to the
point they've just about invalidated a
four-year degree but four-year degrees
are still valid if you study something
that's actually applicable in the
marketplace but getting a degree in
left-handed puppetry is still stupid
regardless of whether it's a
certification or a four-year degree i
don't care what it is not a big call for
left-handed puppetry you're going to
have trouble with this one so
this is the problem so then you go back
to this individual question and say okay
what's an audio engineer's life look
like
i live in nashville
they live on a bus
because they're they're out on tour
that's what an audio engineer does in
this city unless they're the top of the
top and then they're in the studio
producing albums that's correct with the
producers on the slides
moving the slide right and so the audio
engineer in that setting they're going
to they're going to know the mics
they're going to be able to put this
make the sound happen for the artist and
in a town where music and it revolves
they got a hard road and they don't make
a lot and they're on a bus they're a
glorified roadie
okay except for the best of the best of
the best unless you're touring with
freaking brad paisley or something okay
um or you're in a studio situation and
in this town that's what audio engineer
means now we've got some in the building
that do really good yes uh working for
us uh we're spoken word we're not as
hard to tune up as as music is
except for my voice but um anyway the uh
so you know you got to look at it and go
okay what's he want to do and why does
he want to do this oh three of his beer
drinking buddies are hanging out with
some band guys well this is a dumb butt
idea then that's right then there's then
the concern is is valid but here's the
other thing if you do some research and
you find out that you know audio
engineer somewhat limited financially
got to be careful parents you still
don't step on your kids spirit while
still guiding them so for instance dig
into why audio engineer what do you like
about the work dive in a little bit
deeper and what you might find is some
clues not might you will find some clues
that you can then say to your kid hey so
you like doing this this and this here's
a couple of other paths that allow you
to do similar work that have a greater
opportunity and all of a sudden your kid
goes oh you're not trying to redirect me
mom and dad you're actually diving in to
why i love or why i'm interested yeah
because if you're interested is three
your beer drinking buddies think it's
glamorous to travel on the back of a bus
yes these are people that have not
traveled in the back of a bus that's
correct i've been on buses on tour i've
been i've toured travel is glamorous for
people who don't do it
that's what it is and so it's a pain in
the butt you learn to hate airports and
tsa
buses and diesel smell you learn to hate
all of it it's what you do to get to do
the five hours of fun that you get to do
when you do actually get to the city and
so if they think you know so you need to
dig into what is he really looking at
here i don't know what he's really
looking at i'm just calling out what
could be going on with a 19 year old so
um you know but but
your discussion is a good discussion
that's why we're having it and that is
is the technical
degree or the technical certification
route
if it is a valid and booming
area of the economy
yes
i would do that
you know i would not tell my kid to go
get a four-year degree in information
systems right now no
i would tell i would tell them to do
technical search
and and learn the you know learn
programming learn whatever it is on
technical search and open up that way
it's a lot shorter path and the stuff
you're studying on a call on a four-year
college campus on in computer science
today's outdated by the time you get out
of school it's completely useless yeah
and because stuff is changing too fast
and if you're not got your fingers in it
all day long right now in the technical
world you're just out you're already
behind i know i i can tell you when a
computer around here is obsolete when we
get it out of the box
it changes that fast
and so you got to look at what is going
on with the cert i mean are you willing
to you do they you know welders oh my
gosh what welders are getting paid
oh
got it got a real
hand-eye coordination thing going
spatially especially intelligent yeah
man and so there's lots of times we are
micro
us we're good big fans of the trades
we're big fans of certs but all certs
aren't good
you need to know where it's taking him
what ken was saying is really good
advice where is it taking him where is
he going to end up with this path
and then you go about the path if that's
what's necessary this is the ramsey
shaft
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me 130 000 all
thanks to what i learned at bethel tech
you could be next get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money in the lobby of ramsay
solutions on the debt-free stage chris
and brianna are with us hey guys how are
you good how are you dude better than i
deserve welcome where do you all live
pensacola florida cool welcome to
nashville and all the way here to do a
debt-free screen absolutely how much did
you pay off
156 or 158 704
good for you how long did that take 21
and a half months good for you excellent
and your range of income during that
almost two years
120 up to about 160.
good we all do for a living
paralegal
up until a month before we finished i
was a private investigator but thanks to
mr coleman i did some networking and the
used the proximity principles and landed
a job with an insurance company oh wow
very nice
it's great that he was here today so a
lot what do you do what do you do with
the insurance company i'm a a field
claims rep now oh good good for you
nice move yeah okay so what kind of debt
was this 159 000 well we had two credit
cards a car loan
a 401k repayment loan
my student loan
at our home mortgage you paid off your
weight
[Applause]
sure did
look at the weird people
i love it what's this house worth
265.
it's all yours yes sir all yours and we
made the last payment when we got home
we took our shoes off and walked through
the grass we sure did and it felt
different yes sir did it's your grass
yeah baby
so i gotta ask really quick chris
there's a lot of emotion on you and you
told us that what's that from well
before i met her
2005 i had a both of my kidneys failed
oh and you know i was just a broken
human being at 38 years old and
started all over and when i met her
about 2018 we started talking about a
life insurance and it was hard for me to
get it was expensive and then
she'd been listening today for a while
but in 2019 we're on her way to virginia
and uh she goes do you want to listen to
a podcast
so sure after about
10 debt free screams i looked at her and
i said we can do this
and she goes do you think
so
in 2019 uh we were right out here we
went to a concert i took her to see
hooting the blowfish at bridgestone in
september 2019 but on our way home
we pulled out in that parking lot and i
said this is where we're going to be as
soon as we finish this but
um
just that feeling when when you have a
kidney transplant you think it's all
over
and we don't you don't know what you're
going to do about life insurance
something happens to me she would have
to struggle
but there's no more struggling there
we're free there it is we are free
that's beautiful just like you say dave
you live like no one else later you can
give and live like no one else i love
it's just i wish everyone could feel
what i've what we're feeling i wish they
could that's powerful man that's great
that's powerful so brianna how did you
run into us
a friend through church was doing the
program and just kind of checking it out
so i heard about it that way and started
listening to the podcasts okay
and so then you had then you used the
old get in the car for vacation sneak
attacks
that's a good sneak attack she's trapped
in the car you can't go anywhere but
it's just amazing everyone has their own
journey and
just just to know that we made it we
were willing to do whatever it took
but she's taught it three times at our
church financial peace oh thank you wow
we're true believers wow very cool
wow that's fun good for you guys all
right brianna you're teaching the class
you guys did it house and everything are
paid off
uh new people come into the class brand
new and they say okay how do you do this
how do you get out of debt what do you
tell them the key is
budget you've got to work together
you just have to work together yeah
budget and you gotta how long you all
been married 11 years this past december
was 11 years okay
and uh how how many of those years have
you been working together on money since
19 since the podcast yeah two thousand
yeah really so about three years three
years yeah out of the 11. and now your
house has paid off yes sir
it sure is
that's pretty key advice right there
yeah
it's still surreal when you wake up in
the morning it's hard to believe that
you don't have a payment i don't know
anybody we don't know anybody anything
wow it's a man he's got a job he likes
and
yeah absolutely and and kudos to you but
you know what i heard there is that you
don't fear
you don't fear physical harm anymore
because you know she's taking absolutely
i i mean that's peace i know peace is
different for everybody er it's very
personal but that's a big deal man i i
imagine you you get up with a little
extra spring on your step i i can't even
describe it it's yeah like sometimes i
have to pinch myself this is real yeah
this is real and dave i know people have
said thank you and you i didn't do
anything but you've provided a road map
and the passion in which you do it it's
infectious and we've we listen every
morning we've listened at dinner and
those debt-free screams are what kept us
motivated and i think that's what
everyone just keep motivated it'll
happen and now you are one yes we are
[Music]
oh my gosh brianna what was uh what was
the thing about this that you thought
was really going to be hard and it
turned out to be easier
you know i thought that the
the work that would go into it that just
being together on this
because we had been you know we were
older a little bit when we got married
and and we were very used to being sort
of on our own working hard but kind of
in our own directions i think it was a
little easier to maybe get on the same
page than than we thought it may be
rice and beans has nothing on dialysis i
can tell you that oh great statement hey
let me ask you when did in this process
did you change jobs uh it was a month
before we finished i one of the i was a
manager for a private investigative
company uh during our journey and about
four months in before i changed jobs i
just i was burned out you know there's
nowhere else to go yeah and i'd been
talking to one of our clients told her
that i was interested in being a claims
rep and
she you know we talked and she gave me a
few ideas
told me how to tweak my resume just a
little bit and within two months i had a
phone call and interview how big of a
bump did you get um
it was about nine thousand dollars and a
company car hey all right all right good
for you wow but it's something i really
enjoy and it was something new and it it
just challenges me now i mean i i've
been in that uh pi business for 28 years
and just wasn't a whole lot left for me
to do yeah
way to go you guys so fun
well we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires that's definitely the next
chapter in your story you are on the way
well done well done you got your
investments going now right so yeah good
so you're heading that way good good
stuff and a copy of total money makeover
for you to give away thank you again for
leading all those classes it makes a lot
of difference when people have a place
to go to a class and being a coordinator
is a it's a good way to stay on track
yourself
but it's also a good way to uh a good
type of generosity to lead one of those
classes it's a fun thing to do so well
done you guys very very well done we're
so proud of y'all you're amazing
paid for house and everything all right
chris and brianna pensacola florida 159
000 paid off in 21 months making 120 to
160. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three
two
one we're dead
[Applause]
oh
this is how it's done
well
it never fails to uh to show up that the
ken coleman show with
uh getting yourself in the right career
from paycheck to purpose shows up in the
middle of a debt-free screen they all
work together because this whole thing
that we teach at ramsey works together
it's not a separate
it's not separate subjects that happen
to bump into each other no i mean turns
out when you enjoy your work you're
better at it you make more money which
means you can get out of debt faster
keep in mind he did it in the middle of
their baby steps it didn't throw
anything off oh he actually made more
money he made more money and that's the
whole point we want you to have a bigger
shovel and i gotta say it's just really
amazing you know when you hear that kind
of guttural scream
when somebody goes through tremendous
pain or a tremendous challenge
uh and you get out on the other side
that's the kind of release you see and
it's just beautiful just really
impressive what a great couple and you
know he's talking about motivation your
why your why your why for him he didn't
want a physical thing to leave his wife
in any kind of a tough situation what's
your why connect your why to this
journey it's going to go fast yeah
and you know the weirdest of all is uh
now that there's no doubt his health
always improves it's amazing yeah
although after that scream i do want to
have his kidneys looked out
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america we're
glad you're here open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your
life your money your career your
relationships it's all right here on the
ramsey show arnold is with us in miami
hi arnold welcome to the ramsey show
thank you guys for taking my call dave
how are you and ken doing today better
than we deserve what's up
good to hear so i found you guys about
six or seven months ago and i'm on baby
step six now so
being at baby step six obviously my
intention is to pay down the home as
fast as possible but i wanted to revisit
step number four so
with my current employer
between their contribution and my
contribution i'm at 15 but it's a
pension
so outside of that
i also contribute to 15 in mutual funds
i want to know
between the 15 that i'm doing in that
pension and the 15 in mutual funds is
that too much is there like a
calculation where
i can determine whether i should be
saving more of that so you're saving 30
you're saving 30 of your income
right essentially yeah that's too much
yeah that's my more than we would
recommend while you're in baby steps
four five and six we recommend you save
15 of your income
and but not not what your employer puts
in but what you put in
right what do you put in and whatever
you put in is 15
of your household income should be going
into retirement at baby step four
and um the rest of it starts going on
the five kids college if you don't have
that or if that's taken care of then
beyond that everything else goes on the
house until the house is paid for now
this is just temporary for the five to
ten years that it takes to pay off your
house when your house is paid off then
boom you head right you head right on
out and you
load up everything you max out
everything at that point dallas is in
utah hi dallas welcome to the ramsay
show
hey dave can you hear me okay sure
what's up
okay so i just have a question for you
my wife and i are finishing up baby step
two currently um
we we live in a town home right now that
we bought a couple years ago but our
goal is to uh buy a house and or build a
house in the next two years or so
my question is with all of our credit
cards canceled and all of our other
credit gone is that going to
drop our
credit score down
by just paying our mortgage to where we
wouldn't be able to get a construction
loan love to get your advice on thanks
if you have closed every single thing
except your mortgage you should get a
normal your credit score should almost
disappear
but if you just if you only have a
mortgage payment you should be able to
get a loan you may have to go to
churchill and do manual underwriting
because you're kind of a little bit in
no man's land because you actually do
have some you can't you have an account
that's open it's your mortgage so you
will be you could be generating some
kind of a credit score and it could be a
low one
but um what you've got to do is just
show some com get someone that's making
a loan based on common sense
meaning that here we have a guy debt
free that has all of his income except
his mortgage available to pay this loan
and so yes you would qualify but you if
they only make the decision on a credit
score you may not even have a credit
score so you wouldn't be able to get it
then anyway so you've got to do someone
that does manual underwriting
okay and would that work for a
construction loan as well i'm not too
sure on that well it depends on who's
making the construction loan same
situation you've got you know you may be
working with your local credit union
who's looking at the actual facts
rather than a simple number
the problem with credit scored lending
and it's become
it's showing up everywhere now it's the
problem with a lot of dumbed down things
is that it if
people can only make decisions based on
the number
they they miss out on
good customers
because they miss out on the nuances of
the situation for instance i have a zero
credit score
and uh and i've you know i've got a net
worth of hundreds of millions of dollars
uh but i can't borrow money from someone
that only makes a loan based on a credit
score uh so the joke is i can't rent an
apartment but i can buy the complex for
cash
you know so that's the thing you got to
remember about this and you just gotta
decide how you're gonna work into it and
uh you're heading in the right way but
there is no magic pill here and keeping
all your stupid accounts open just to
qualify for a mortgage is a really dumb
idea and and really that's what we get
into all the time ken
yeah and and here's the deal the there's
he's going to be able to with the
financial direction they're in they're
going to be able to build they're going
to be able to buy you know i understand
the source of the question but the
reality is is people that live debt-free
you can do it you don't have to have a
high credit score so it's a little bit
of unnecessary fear but that's what the
financial institutions have been driving
at everybody it's almost like everybody
thinks the credit score is the the
ticket to a beautiful future because
they've made it one they've made it that
but it's also but you can do it without
it oh really absolutely absolutely
all right gabriel's with us in detroit
hi gabriel welcome to the ramsay show
hey uh how are you guys great man what's
up
uh
good news and bad news
um
bad news a lot of debt good news um are
you guys
the the other bad news is i was here
before
i was a listener
i i started the baby steps
and then probably the last two years i
want to say it just started falling off
you know the wagon getting back on
credit cards thinking i could pay it by
the end of the month
and that turned into within two years
roughly 35 000 of credit card debt
and i'm at a point where the last six
months it's been extremely difficult to
just maintain so
i
went the route of consolidating my debt
and paying this company who would
brokerage a deal
at that point
you know seven months into this program
i'm
extremely skeptical i'm not
as aware as i thought i was what's
happening with with the money and
it's like
i never really had the reins in the
first place but now for sure i don't
have
an idea where the reins are
and uh
i'm pretty much at the
at the point where there's no more
savings
and uh credit card debt did you run up
gabriel
30 35 what do you make of here
i make um
i make about 70 and my wife makes about
uh 25.
okay so you have 105 or 100 or 95 000
household income and thirty thousand
dollars in credit card debt
okay how much is your car debt
uh car debt i have uh 13 000.
and what's that card what's that car
worth
um
there's two uh one is a minivan one's a
truck uh the minivan is um i owe 5700 on
it it's roughly
a 6 000 minivan the truck um currently
it's
under repair so i'm trying to get it
back on the road but that one is
probably worth um
nine or ten and it's uh
at about seven thousand dollars and dead
on that one
okay
and uh how long you been married
uh married since all nine so um going on
so are you and your you and your wife um
you sound kind of uh depressed a little
bit
like down in the dumps
yeah that'd be nice
um
are you tired enough of the chaos and
the disorganization to now fix it
finally yeah yeah
and hopefully this time for good never
go back
absolutely yeah
okay
well i've been where you've been where
you are um i've done stupid and
got the opportunity to live through it
and um you're gonna be okay
but here's the thing there's a
tremendous power
and joy
in taking control again
cleaning up the mess
lining it up and starting to knock it
off one at a time one at a time one at a
time and that's going to involve
cancelling your contract with the stupid
debt consolidation people getting the
credit cards out and cutting them up
we're going to get you on a budget
you're going to sell so much stuff the
kids think they're next you're not going
on vacation and you're not going into a
restaurant but you knew i was going to
say all that didn't you
yeah
now the question is are you going to do
it
yeah okay then i'll show you how
we'll get you into financial peace
university hold on kelly i'll sign you
up and i'll pay for it
and the two of you get in there but by
god gabriel this time do it son
do it life's too short to live this day
like this you're getting the crap beat
out of you by this stuff time for you to
stand back up and shake it off move on
to the next thing
i understand i'm not picking on you for
falling off the wagon but let's go fix
it
last time forever hold on kelly i'll
pick up
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality host of the ken
coleman show and uh the author of the
best-selling book
pay from paycheck to purpose is here
we'll be talking about your careers
we'll be talking about your work your
relationships your mental health your
parenting your marriage and your money
we do all of it right here at the ramsey
show thank you for joining us john
starts off this hour he's in colorado hi
john how are you
how you doing dave appreciate you taking
my call sure man what's up
well i've been an on-off listener to you
for a few years now and i think i don't
think i've ever heard this question
posed to you before uh what do you guys
have advice for somebody that's kind of
living with the death sentence and if i
may um
give you a little uh brief overview of
what my situation is
sure
well um when i was born i was born with
my leg you know shorter than my other
one i went through a bunch of surgeries
the first one i was seven days old uh
went for about 13 more went to the
shriners hospital which was a great
facility there in eastern texas
got uh fixed up with my leg well ended
up uh with an autoimmune liver disease
my body started thinking my liver was a
bad thing and it was probably due to all
those anesthesia drugs etc etc so i
ended up getting an autoimmune disease
since i was 17. i'm about to turn 50
years old dave uh here in april
uh um my mom and dad uh they've been
marrying 53 years i've had a very strong
you know church bound a very strong
family behind me my mom told me that i
had a brain just because i couldn't dig
ditches i wasn't going to be some ssi
kid and she was going to make me use my
brain so i you know went through college
they didn't have much i had to keep my
grades up to pay for all my schooling uh
i did become an mri tech i've been an
mri tech now for 28 years wow i've been
having this all a roller coaster ride of
uh you know off and on to these meds and
seven years ago i was probably you know
up for a liver transplant i refused to
do that day because i'm just playing out
tired but i did my own research and i
found a way to fix myself and it bought
me about another seven years well here i
am at seven years my condition is
getting worse
now uh i make 77
791.81 a year uh i can only afford to
pay uh put 10 in my 401 k but i've had
to pay you know the route that i decided
to save myself with the insurance
doesn't pay of course so you know that i
took a big hit seven years ago so i only
got about maybe 40 000 in my 401k my i
only can afford to put 10 months because
it costs me about two to three hundred
dollars in supplements and so forth and
so forth so uh your your your plan
doesn't seem to be a viable plan for
someone like me i they're telling me now
that i probably got maybe another seven
eight years i don't have any debt other
than i just bought a town home uh last
year i just paid off my car i'm looking
for another beater because right now you
don't want to buy a car right now
because the prices are through the roof
so i'm just kind of hoping this thing
lasts me for a while uh i do have a
small little rock ira with only about
fifteen hundred dollars and or i'm sorry
three thousand dollars in it i stopped
going there because i wasn't fine uh
comfortable with my financial advisor
that was advising there so i just
stopped contributing to it for the as a
point um so i'm basically sitting here
thinking that i have a
life insurance i want to be able to
leave my niece and my nephew something
and my sister uh my parents are in their
70s i'm close to them uh so i go down
and take care of them best i can
but like i'm saying is
i know i'm never going to be a rich
person i just don't even have the time
to do it but i i want to be able to find
uh it's been difficult to me because i
want to find some financial advice that
somebody's not appreciative of my
situation john i i
um i can't imagine facing what you've
been facing i mean you've been a fighter
you've been a fighter your whole life
um yeah it's been rough
every time every time they tell you
you're done you get another seven years
is the story i heard so i'm not sure
you're as done as you're
describing um
and i i suspect that something will come
along because and if it does you'll find
it
that will uh be a way to do this um
so here's the thing well basically my
question my
ahead my question is basically dave is i
want to be able to make sure i'm not
wasting money on all these insurances
and
stuff that i got crap like that i want
to be able to leave them something but
still i want to be able to enjoy my life
right now you're not wasting money on
insurance if it's taking care of you
okay and taking care of you is more
important than you leaving a niece or a
nephew i have like aflac policies and i
know you're not a fan of those you know
good health insurance work your plan
i have it through my work okay i have it
through my work
i have all that said i just want to make
sure that you got the wrong goal
your goal of leaving your niece and
nephew money is the wrong goal the right
goal is to take care of you
i'm fine right now no you're not
you're not you're not fine you don't
have any money you don't have any margin
in what you're talking about and you're
sitting here telling me that the idea of
living on lesson you make and avoiding
debt and building up wealth is not for
you well it is for you
do you have exactly the same timeline as
everyone else no you don't
um you but you're a fighter i guess
that's what you're a scrapper and you
know what i would do is i would have you
build up savings
stay out of debt
which you have done a great job of and
uh you know don't don't leave a bunch of
debt behind but don't worry about having
an insurance policy for a niece or a
nephew you need to take care of you
and what money you can scrape together
let's spend on your health and on some
solutions and on some life extension
things and something quality of life
things and spend that on you and that is
not selfish
you have been dealt a hand of cards and
you've been a scraper and a fighter and
you've done a great job i'm very proud
of what you've pulled off
but i disagree with your premise that
our plan doesn't work for you maybe
you're going to adjust some of the
nuances of it but our plan is save money
live on less than you make be generous
live on a plan a written budget stay out
of debt that's our plan and you've done
that by and large so you've done a good
job ken yeah i agree john i i think that
you feel some sense of pressure and i
think you have to let go of that find
out why you feel this pressure to to
leave something behind for your niece
and nephew there's nothing wrong with
that that's very good-hearted but i also
think that it's created a narrative that
dave has has really uh enlightened you
to and and you don't need to feel that
you if you want to live a life that you
enjoy and have a quality of life which
is what you just said a moment ago i
think you have the finances all ready to
do that and i think that's what you
focus on and then if there is something
left over get a good financial advisor
one of our smart investor pros that does
have the heart of a teacher let them
guide you you understand everything
they're guiding you on and then you
leave it behind but
seven years or seventeen years from now
when someone steps into the pulpit and
delivers your eulogy
it needs to be
john was a fighter john was a scrapper
he's self-sustained he always took care
of himself and he was always generous
not he left
money to his niece and nephew
this is not where your greatness comes
from your greatness comes from who you
already are john
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
many of you have been filing your taxes
the same way with the same old software
for years but you're actually sick and
tired of it you don't like the add-on
fees you don't like the ads trying to
sell you
debt while you're just trying to do your
taxes
the reality for most people is they
think it's free but when they get into
it it's not really free
by the time you realize you don't meet
the free criteria you put in too much
time to start over somewhere else so you
pay up folks are making a killing off of
you this way and we think you deserve
better that's why we're offering ramsey
smart tax
so you can file your taxes online
without paying more than you were told
ramsey smart tax includes every form you
need with no hidden fees no surprises
even have a promo code right now and you
can do the federal taxes for free
and if you'd prefer
to have a priority support situation
extended audit protection you can go
with a premium version
it's a whole twenty dollars
that's rough i'm telling you
if you're ready to ditch the other guys
for surprising you
selling you out and trying to sell you
crap
instead of just letting you do your
taxes go to ramsey solutions dot com
slash smart tax get started right now
ramsey solutions dot com slash smart tax
will is with us in denver i will welcome
to the ramsey show
hi ken hi dave how's it going better
than we deserve what's up
well your phone screener tells me i have
a good question so hope you agree
okay i've been listening to you
sometimes i agree with her
what's up sometimes you get called
stupid and arrogant
that's happened too wow will bringing it
today this better be a good question
will with that kind of intro
i'm an avid viewer like i said i get
even the most expensive it was one of my
favorite calls of the last year by the
way
yeah that was that's one of the most
popular calls of the last year
so good call out
it's not just popular on your channel
all the other channels are talking about
it too it's it's lighting up my youtube
feed sorry what was any more time um
so i've been losing you about half my
life like i said and i have been very
inspired by what you said about giving
um i've had the opportunity over the
past couple years to you know be able to
give big or what's big to me
to people on an individual level and
that's been every bit as rewarding as
you said it would be
as far as the baby steps i now have my
emergency fund and recently became a
homeowner i'd like to start using some
of my freed up cash to give kind of on
an organizational level
i've heard you talk about the importance
of feeling your giving and i was
wondering how i can go about feeling my
giving
when giving to a cause or organization
as opposed to you know just an
individual
if you can allocate some time in your
calendar to
interact with the people that
is serving
even though you're not handing money
directly to those people
but you're interacting with the people
that it is helping
for instance
let's just say i'll just make up one
let's say it's a a community medical
clinic
that helps the underserved with medical
issues in in a tough neighborhood okay
and you want to give them i'll make up a
number some substantial money call it
ten thousand dollars
okay that would be organizational giving
but you don't you didn't give to the
actual people you gave to the clinic to
take care of them to support them so
they can continue to do the work that
they do we'll go down there and spend a
half a day
and see what they do and talk to the
people that they're serving
and you'll you'll get it you'll get
you'll get it just fine and you really
should do that anyway if you can if
you're going to make a substantial gift
because that's just due diligence to
make sure that your giving is going to
something that is actually
pulling off what it is they claim
they're doing
that makes sense makes sense
absolutely yeah so my daughter
my daughter denise runs our family
foundation and that's actually her job
she spends time with the ministries that
we're going to give to or consider
giving to
to determine that they're really getting
it done that they're really effective we
pretend like we're investing in a
company and we want to make sure that
company is being run well because we're
investing god's money
what are red flags we look for
i'm sorry
what a red flag
what a red flag you look for when you do
this betting i want to know what percent
i look at their budget for one thing in
our case we don't give to ministries to
take on debt because we don't want to
support a bank
we're there to support the ministry and
we don't believe in debt so be a little
inconsistent if we don't borrow money
but we give to something that does so we
don't i'm not saying you have to do that
but that's a red flag we look for uh
another red flag we look for is the
percentage of the
uh
charity work that's
of the in total you know
these these non-profits are all
profitable if a nonprofit that's not
profitable goes out of business
okay it's just an accounting entry that
makes it a non-profit so they have to be
bringing in more than they have going
out or they they go away so how are they
managing that and what percentage of
their top lines so to speak their total
revenue incoming is going to
administrative
versus actually feeding the hungry if
they're supposed to be feeding the
hungry or
buying or providing medical care in the
example i gave a minute ago so i'm
looking for percentages on that
and and you know believe it or not we've
run into things that 90 cents out of
every dollar is going to administrative
and only 10 cents is going to help the
actual people so all we're doing is
paying for people to have a job we're
not paying we're not giving to the
actual person that's in need through
this organization so we don't give to
that one by the way if it's if it's that
high ken what else do you think it's in
that line i would follow right off a
dave after you look at the percentage of
the money on administrative costs versus
whatever the actual product is the
service the type of service i'd be uh
hanging out with those people uh to see
how they run their events you know or
whatever that need that they're uh
serving what's it look like and i think
you can do that when you do what dave
recommended first which is you know just
get around the ministry not just to kind
of see what they're doing but watch how
they run things you know one of the
things i've grown up in ministry one of
the things that i think sometimes we as
investors and i love that dave laid it
out this way we kind of overlook people
because it's while they got a good heart
well the reality is is if if they're not
doing as good as they could be doing to
the point where they're only kind of
addressing a surface issue and they're
mismanaging their time volunteers time
and funds i would look at that too not
from a critical spirit but this is an
investment that you're making and i
would look at that too because if it's
poorly managed and poorly run
that's a problem too it is not mean no
there's a lot of need yeah a lot of need
there's more need than you'll ever have
money
there's someone out there hurting more
a bazillion times more than you'll have
personal money that you can do so what
you what you're looking for
is not the
not not how much the need is real the
need is almost always valid the need is
almost always real the person hurting on
the other end the people needing
assistance on the other end's almost
always very real the question is not the
is the need valid the question is are
you called to the need
number one and then number two are the
people taking care of them competent
and efficient
in taking care of the need um otherwise
you're just wasting your money it's
exactly right it's just a waste and good
intentions
don't mean anything if i intend to send
my wife flowers for valentine's day i
get zero
points so you got good intentions or
bogus i've got a good heart i do have a
good heart i love my wife but i forgot
to send her flowers i didn't by the way
but thank god but um but i mean you know
you know that doesn't mean i'm a bad
person if i forgot it just means i was
incompetent that's correct i didn't do
my job
and so you can't finance that kind of
stuff or you shouldn't finance that
stuff based on he's got a good heart the
need is real but they're not competent
that's correct that's not money that's
not a place you put money that's bad use
of god's resources
and so and that's not to say i hate that
person or i don't believe in the need i
like the person but i just don't believe
in them i don't believe they're
competent i don't believe they're doing
a good efficient job of bringing
healing to that area of need or bringing
help to that area
because here's the flip side if you go
and see several organizations and let's
say three out of four it's kind of like
their pants are on fire that's a warning
sign but you find an organization that's
doing really good work and it's
efficient guess what those dollars that
you're investing are going to come back
with a higher return that's why we're
saying this
on disaster relief
if you put up the red cross beside
samaritan's purse
blow your mind that's how much more
efficient samaritan's purse is
how
light years
they are in terms of carrying baggage
around but both do a good job and both
are serving disasters
which is doing the most efficient
this is the ramsey chef
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey solutions
personality is my co-host today
best-selling author of the book from
paycheck to purpose
you can gather it up at ramsey solutions
that's what i was trying to say dot com
in the lobby i got a lot of rams again
here a lot in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the ramsey debt free stage
is ramsey ramsey and trampoline oh my
gosh they're here eric and brittany are
with us hey guys how are you good hi
dave welcome where do you guys live
tucson arizona good how much have you
paid off we've paid 125
782 dollars love it how long did this
take two years nine months good for you
and uh what was your range of income
during that time about 75 000 to about
105 000. cool what do y'all do for a
living i'm a physical therapist and i'm
an entrepreneur i have several small
businesses but i mostly work in fitness
good for you well done what kind of debt
was this hundred and twenty six thousand
student loans from physical therapy
school oh sallie mae yeah kick the old
woman out
i love it way to go guys so how long
have you two been married uh three years
and three and a half years yeah three
and a half years so right after marriage
you look up and go oh crap there's a lot
of student loans here well it was
actually uh pre-marital counseling we
were doing with our pastor that directed
us uh towards the total money makeover
book and that kind of little fire onto
us he encouraged us to get the book and
so we can i tell you how much i love
your pet
yeah so we bought it and we both read it
right away and we got married in
september so we took like september
october november december to like figure
out how to make our money work together
and what that looked like and then in
january of 2019 we hit the ground
running and we finished in september of
last year wow way to go you guys
so first order of business and marriage
right after the uh
right after the pre-marriage counseling
is get after it yes i like it i like it
good for you guys how fun so how's it
feel to be free
so good so you guys are what were you 27
26 29 29 31 29 31 awesome very good
so none of your contemporaries none of
your running buddies are doing this
hardly unless you talk them into it
we've talked to some people about it but
nobody is where we are we've made an
acolyte of my sister though she listens
to you guys religiously ah okay we're
got one on the one yeah all right what's
her name her name's catherine catherine
shout out
there it is yeah that's worse that's
that's like totally now she has to do it
i know yeah so we're watching 22 million
people now know catherine's doing this
all right good way to go guys love it so
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is you're very
successful um
doing it together yeah doing it together
we did our budget together and the thing
that really helped us was
um visual cues i'm a visual learner and
so like we had a white board where we
listed all of our goals which included
like budgeting and what books we wanted
to read and like trips we wanted to take
and how we were going to do all of those
things how much that we were going to
pay off and then i made like charts that
were on our fridge that we like put
every month okay this is how much we
paid in this month and they were there
next to our budget every month we could
see what we accomplished and where we
were going and seeing those things every
day
was like
the thing that kept us going absolutely
i like it i like it most people are more
visual learners than they realize yeah
and so it never hurts to have something
right there in front of you that's
constantly messing with you and
constantly giving you an atta boy not a
girl saying you did it that was it one
little red line on there is a nice
little thing get to write that on there
you know it's perfect and uh man it's
just uh i've heard some great great
stories about people doing that visual
cues are a big deal yeah so it
definitely helped good job way to go
guys thank you very very fun what was
the hardest part of this for y'all
i think just like keeping going i mean
if we really once we got the snowball
going though we saw like we had early
success and we had i think you had seven
different seven individual loans and
started at the smallest and got things
going and then it's like okay now how
scorched earth was your lifestyle
we did pretty well actually we lived for
a while in a very rural town in colorado
and so cost of living was quite low
there and so that
and we found inexpensive ways to have
some fun in there too
hiking
outdoors that sort of stuff but we we
did pretty well just you know finding
ways to do things that didn't cost a lot
of money and we had a low cost of living
and between that and then the pandemic
putting interest on hold we just kept
plowing forward we were like we are
going to have this paid off before they
put interest back on we're not going to
pay any more interest ever again and
that's really what got us going yeah use
the advantage of that rather than going
this is a chance to kick back and slide
you went on we didn't take a break at
all yeah
wow way to go you guys i'm so proud of
you very well done who are your biggest
cheerleaders outside the two of you
pastor pastor's got to be honest
pastor's on there um our families were
full bore 100 percent um supportive on
us uh went the last two and a half years
we basically said for christmas holidays
birthday we don't want gifts cash is
preferred so we can just throw it onto
that student loan and people did it yeah
people did it parents are here and
that's what they they gave us
cash they gave us checks for all of our
you know holidays and birthdays for the
last few years and we hardly got any
like physical gifts and every dollar
that we got in
went to student loans yeah wow and then
we gave everyone updates you know just
like this
with us
so if you're going to support this
ministry we're going to give you an
update yes exactly
i like it good for you guys well done so
when dave asked you a question a few
moments ago about what was the hardest
part you guys were kind of looking at
each other you really got some momentum
but in that first four months i believe
you said before you started in january
of 19. you guys were trying to figure
this out there had to be some tension
there as a couple trying to figure out
the money you're shaking your head what
was the hardest part about that four
months of learning each other's
behaviors and then making them shared
behaviors well yeah i think i think we
were both like ready to do it like it
wasn't a question of like did we want to
do it yeah it was just like
it felt really daunting to start and
then like we made a budget every month
and we had you know we printed out the
sheets from your website and like you
know we had written it all wrote it all
down so it was all ready for us right
there but like sometimes the first would
roll around and we'd be like oh we have
to budget
[Laughter]
so that was i think that was the hard
part and like getting going
just getting started was the hard part
yeah
but then once the momentum kicked you
know it is weird
that that first step of actually the
problem with the first month of doing
the budget is you are now saying out
loud we're going to do this yes and
there's a little bit of fear of
of making that commitment because you're
afraid well now i said it i got to do it
you know it's like you get sucked into
the vortex you know and you can't get
out yeah
i know i was intimidating it's
intimidating yeah yeah but the good news
is once you take that first step it just
pop up
and it picks up you know and it got
easier as we got going we started to
understand
where our money was going even more that
like
we did the budget but we didn't need it
as like in the forefront because we
started to figure out okay like this
this goes to this and this goes to this
and it wasn't as it becomes
yeah it becomes a game yeah and the game
slows down once you get moving yeah
that's that's amazing i don't mean slows
down literally i mean
that thing they talk about with athletes
when you when you catch a zone when you
get in the flow
everything just seems to slow down and
you can do it you don't think about it
yeah it just became automatic yeah going
get groceries like oh okay i know i've
got this number in my head this is where
i'm looking for
or whatever it was yeah we were always
planning for whatever
if we were gonna take a little getaway
we were like planning to make sure that
we were ready to do that or like you
know budgeted for the getaway or
christmas or whatever it was we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
number one bestseller how ordinary
people built extraordinary wealth how
you can too that's your next chapter to
go on and be millionaires and you're
going to no question about it i'm proud
of you all thank you well done also a
copy of total money makeover for you to
give away and stir up someone else is
holy ruckus i love it well done eric and
brittany tucson arizona 126 000 paid off
all student loans pt is now free two
years and nine months making 75 to 105.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
[Applause]
yeah baby
this is awesome man oh man oh man
wow
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 11 2
when pride comes then comes disgrace but
with humility
comes wisdom
teddy roosevelt said be practical as
well as generous in your ideals
keep your eyes on the stars but remember
to keep your feet on the ground
roosevelt was almost as good as
churchill at
popping off one-liners churchill might
have been the king yeah i think that's a
really good that'd be a fun kind of
historical exercise for nerds like us
but you're right both of them had a way
with words uh
you know and back in those days they
talk differently that we talk now you
know i mean they said things in
different words but they the depth of
that stage they spoke more eloquently
that's a great depth statement i don't
think either one of them ever said yeah
no
no
no
tom is with us in jacksonville florida
hey tom what's up
hey what's going on hey man we're gonna
make it how can we help
hey so i got kind of a scriptural
question for you and then then a
follow-up about uh what i should do
about it
so i took a job selling solar panels in
in florida
and my original plan
was to you know develop my sales skills
and earn money at the job while i'm
building my own business on the side
and i've been doing it for a few weeks
and
what i've started to realize is
i'm not really selling solar panels as
much as i'm selling the loans the
financing for them
and this is kind of making me want to
reevaluate uh what i'm doing with the uh
with the job so
um i'll explain how the company
uh
trains the financing because i want to
hear your opinion on that
um oh i know and then okay yeah okay so
and then and then
and then i want to know like you know if
you think i should just keep it moving
and focus on building my business
full-time instead of you know doing this
so
and yeah you might already know this but
i'll just i'll just run through real
quick so that's okay you don't you don't
need to run through it they basically
sell it for
the savings
on the electric bill due to having solar
panels will pay your payments
and we endorse uh solar panel companies
in several cities but we do never
endorse them
doing financing and we never endorse
anyone doing financing because we don't
believe in debt and that's an obvious
thing but that doesn't necessarily
affect you that's us
and uh but it's a standard thing in that
business they use the savings to pay the
payments is that is the sales pitch and
then they usually sell the paper and
sometimes they make a cajillion dollars
on the paper when they sell it as well
depending on the company and how jacked
up the financing situation is ken how do
you think you address this from an
ethical standpoint
i think from an ethical standpoint i
don't think you're doing anything
ethically wrong or legally wrong but it
isn't and clear uh it's it's a clear
violation in your mind of your values of
what you believe in and that is okay but
i think we've got to take we have to
separate what you disagree with versus
you doing something wrong and so i would
quickly try to look for another sales
job but i'd stay where i am until i can
replace
my
day-to-day income here's why you're
probably not able to pay your bills with
your side hustle is that true or false
yeah currently no yeah so you got to
look at this as a math situation so when
you can get to the point where you can
pay a large portion of what you're
making now at least to take care of your
basic needs then you're ready to go full
time until then you're not so you're not
doing anything ethically wrong i start
looking for another sales job that will
allow you to make the money you're
making now maybe even more which will
continue to allow continue to give you
stability to allow you to grow the side
business but you're not
you're not breaking the law
therefore this isn't an ethical thing
this is a values thing and don't make
any crazy jumps nothing for you to be
ashamed of or feel guilty of you've seen
the light take your time find something
replace it move on yeah it you know
there's a lot of things you can sell
that you don't have to sell through
financing
lots and lots of things uh that's
optional you know that um not everybody
that buys a car finances it not
everybody that buys a solar panel's
finances there for that matter
and um i'm a big believer in solar
panels uh in certain situations uh the
the current technology is far superior
to what it was even a decade ago
and so the break-even analysis on it is
real but i would pay cash for them or i
wouldn't buy them but i say that about
everything there's nothing i would pay i
would buy that i wouldn't pay cash for
if it's valid or not valid whatever it
is no i mean whether it's just a stupid
luxury item or whether something's gonna
actually break even on it
so that's the way i view it uh and so if
but if this company is jacked up and you
know like you're disobeying your
superior if you don't cram financing
down their throat and you're
uncomfortable doing that then it's time
to look for something else to sell until
you get your side gig moving
because you're not in alignment with
them and you're not going to be
comfortable doing it
so hey man thanks for the call you know
i'll tell you where else i ran into that
was the underwear place victoria's
secret
they um
i didn't run into the underwear
placement the way that was said i didn't
run into it but a lady that was working
there was tell me she she said if they
don't uh if they don't sell if they're
working the floor right a sales person
and they don't sell
uh a certain number of credit cards a
day get certain number of applications a
day for the victoria's secret credit
card they get fired oh wow yeah so i
mean it's nothing about there's nothing
about selling the small underwear it's
about selling credit that's right well
that's happening in a lot there was no
there was no quota on amount of
underwear sold no just the financing
card you know just just whether or not
you got the victoria's secret card yeah
and so best buy is about the same way oh
big time best buy is a horrid
mess
you can get really good buys in best buy
on things if you just pay for them but
they make because they don't have a lot
of margin no they don't make a lot of
money on tv those tvs are not a bad buy
at all
you'd be hard-pressed to beat their
prices you can find you can beat them
that's true but uh good good prices but
the um
but they make all their money on
extended warranties and on financing and
the stupid best buy credit card my god
they will put an extended warranty on
the number two pencil over there yeah i
mean i never saw anything like it they
were just um it's the same place that
rooms that goes
it's just walking you can't even get out
through the register no you got a 19
year old hanging around your ankles
until you sign the extended warranty you
know it's like it's ridiculous it's true
and um
just but but what amounts to is is they
they got sideways when they realize they
can make more money on the issuing of
credit than they could on the sale of
solar panels
they got sideways when they realized
they could make more money on the
issuing of credit than they could the
sale of televisions or more money on the
extended warranties than they could the
actual television that's correct and so
and card you know used car dealers man
somebody's used car warranties are
unfreaking believable rip-offs so you've
just gotta you know you
you cannot be successful at something
when you feel like you're not doing
right for the customer yep long-term you
you can't look at yourself in the mirror
and go i i wouldn't do this to my
brother i wouldn't do this to my mother
i wouldn't do this to my best friend
then you don't need to be doing it
that's correct but don't make a bad
financial decision meaning leave a job
without something to walk into because
you feel bad you're a good person you're
not doing anything illegal be smart yeah
dave here's something i got to ask you
about because i'm you're absolutely
right
about you know these companies like best
buy they understand people are just are
so needy for stuff that they're in the
finance business i got to ask you this i
saw a headline over the weekend
that there are huge swaths of the
american public that are paying
several thousand dollars above msrp for
a car oh yeah and i just don't
understand why people feel like they've
got to have a car that bad a brand new
car
uh
sales
yeah i mean it's it's marketing and
sales yeah i mean and it's just it's uh
scarcity and urgency you know i i was
talking about that day rachel was making
fun of me because we had a guy call in
want to buy a new car and i still
wouldn't go with it because he said he
could get a sticker and the hot cars are
going for more than a sticker so he
thinks it's a bargain that's a bargain
yeah so
but cart used cars are going up right
well you think this is a can you think
this is a trend that's going to continue
for 10 years come on man it's not going
to but i have a good friend that went to
look at a hundred thousand dollar
vehicle sticker on is 107
and uh the guy told him you know he said
okay so you know i'm gonna bite it in
voice and he goes uh no these cars are
sticker
full sticker
let me play msrp
he goes yeah he goes if you go to the
other dealership across town for this
hundred thousand dollar car it's a 20
000 oversticker oh yeah he goes we're
the good guys we're selling it at
sticker
and i'm like oh
yeah
i
think i'll sit this one out boys and
girls
and you know that's what's interesting
the power of the people if people would
realize if you would just say no to your
urge and you stopped doing this the car
deals would have to drop the price well
we can't control that
it's all about demand yeah the shortage
of supply and demand and that's it's a
that's why it's driven all this stuff up
artificially and it's going to come
right back down
on some of this you know lumber
cars you don't worry about those they're
going to come back down it's not a
bubble it's just a supply demand curve
that puts us out of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you